So think about this scenario. You're sitting in class. Your professor is
telling you everything that's going to be on your exam, and you really need to
write all this down, but you forgot a pen so the girl next to you lends you
one. Okay, now you have your pen, back to focusing on what the professor is
saying. And ignoring the fact that the room is freezing and the guy to your
right is smacking his gum. Oh, man, there's so much on the slide to write down
before the professor moves on, hurry, write, write, write, but wait. Why are
people laughing? You look around and you notice that people are looking at a
guy standing outside the window with roses. And a huge sign that says I love
you Torry, be mine. The girl next to you said that guy recited a poem using
like ten poster boards, while doing an interpretive dance. How on earth did you
miss that? Well, back to writing before the slide changes. You're almost done
writing the list of topics for your final when you hear two people behind you
talking about your favorite band and saying they're going to the concert next
week. Oh, man, you've got to get tickets for that concert. Oh no. Slide just
changed. Okay, now you have to focus on your professor's closing remarks.
Because this is the essay portion of the exam. You know, it's going to be hard,
but you can do it. Okay, so now class is over. You turn and give the pen back
to the girl you borrowed it from, but you notice that she's not there, it's a
guy sitting next to you and he's sleeping on his desk. When did that happen?